talking about weird stuff though let's
talk about what you guys do the babylon
b oh thanks because
good transition good transition no but i
mean like you're you're you are
figuratively throwing pies
you're you're calling out you're calling
out hidden truth as it were through
jokes a good example is when you guys
had an article that said
in genius move donald trump comes out in
support of impeachment forcing democrats
to oppose
and that is a very clever way to comment
on the fact that they just oppose
whatever it is trump or you know trump
supporters are doing yeah yeah he said
it therefore it's bad orange man bad
orange man bad
well that's that goes back to how
everybody's like a bot you know that's
bot behavior to just have a predictable
response to whatever it you know there's
something that you're supposed to be
opposed to so you just you oppose it
i don't know i mean with the internet
though you know instagram and all these
things there's
people are
just trying to do what you're supposed
to do on these platforms everyone's that
has the same family pictures they all do
the same things but if you're trying to
throw pies and be disruptive then that's
your thing you're trying to do it it has
to be something that you're not
deliberately trying to do it just has to
be coming from you naturally it's
because that's how you are as a person
you're different otherwise you're both
doing something for a purpose you're
trying to get a certain kind of response
people are either trying to fit in or
they're trying to be different i mean
get a response by being different that's
true i i don't i i don't take issue with
someone being like let's throw a pie
figuratively because you know don't
actually throw pies at people but uh
like when i'm on twitter i'll just
randomly i'll post some nonsense if i'm
feeling like it like i posted jeremiah
was a bullfrog the other day because i
just i just you know yeah yeah i thought
it was fun you need to be more
responsible it was it was a whim
literally i was listening to three dog
night and so joy of the world came on
and i just typed in and hit enter and i
didn't think twice
and i was like so you made a point about
people being thoughts and we've sort of
talked about this a little bit there are
obviously some issues where it makes
sense to to stand strong have base
principles so when you're talking about
something where you would say there is
an axiomatic evil or you're talking
about like abortion or some matter of
like human sexuality such as
homosexuality you're talking about theft
property etc it makes sense that you
would have set positions because of what
your principles are but then when it
comes to a question of whether a
specific person is guilty
in a court case or a national story
that's not something you can just jump
to one side of the other run that's
something you have to see evidence for
but we are at the point where anytime
there is a news story about a police
officer shooting someone
a large
subsection of the country has decided
he's guilty and it was unjustified
without any evidence at all
conservatives are still
are still defending ahmed armory
like yeah that one that one that one to
me is like
because we had lawyers on talking about
that i think my point is there are a lot
of stories that we see in the public eye
where it's just a question of a specific
person their behavior whether they're
guilty of the thing that they're accused
of and people are hyper-polarized on it
and i think this has happened because
we're just used to being hyper-polarized
but it's different right because again
when it comes to the other issues it's a
matter of principle whether a specific
person is guilty or innocent when i
don't have evidence is not something
that my principles can determine it's
something the evidence will determine
once we get it but people take sides
before they see or hear anything of
substance about that and the entirety of
the left including establishment
democrats moderate liberals default
liberals and leftists
will blindly march in lockstep yep
they'll get angry about it they'll
protest about it and they'll scream in
your face and try and take your job and
conservatives are lukewarm and we'll be
like okay we'll agree with you on that
one yeah and the fun thing about satire
is it gives you a way to point all of
that out in a way that like makes the
point you know right it makes it into a
joke where you're you're seeing that and
you're exposing it for what it is the
absurdity of it did you see the uh
subverting it fast company wrote an
article saying something like beware the
far-right comedy or whatever or
right-wing comedy and they're like from
joe rogan to the babylon b to like the
daily wire and i just think it's funny
that uh
they they still try and push these memes
where they're like the right can't make
jokes or it's not funny but the weird
thing is
it used to be the perception that that
conservatives weren't funny and the left
was there was in the article they talk
about how fox tried doing some kind of
john stewart show back in the day that
just didn't work and it failed but now
you've got gutfeld who who on fox news
he's he gets way way better ratings than
any of the primetime com comedians on on
major networks you take a look at the
onion bro i imagine that that used to
read the onion yeah of course what
happened to them
so the problem a lot of the reason why
these late night comedians and the onion
and whatever are falling off is because
they're not
what the comedian the satirist the
humorist is supposed to be doing
is poking holes in the popular narrative
not promoting it you know all they do is
push it all they do is push it and the
big tech companies are you know trying
to rig the systems that you're not
allowed to poke holes in the popular
narrative if you do that then you're
engaging in hate speech or you're
spreading misinformation or whatever but
this is what's killing comedy in my
opinion you know they say oh we're not
funny well we have more engagement in
traffic than the onion at this point
we're the we're the most popular satire
site in the world and they're and
they're sitting there saying we're not
funny well obviously we're engaging
people and the reason we're engaging
people is because we're actually making
fun of the powers that be and trying to
uh hold that power accountable and poke
holes in the popular narrative instead
of promote it which is what comedians
are supposed to do i i grew up with the
onion because i think they were based on
what milwaukee i think and i remember
when we would get the physical onion
paper uh when we're in chicago look at
this one excerpts from jenny thomas's
emails attempting to overturn the 2020
election cnn no it's too political is
that yeah right it's like i could say
they weren't political in the early days
this is the thing
that was actually funny there's one
here's one well you're going to reach
your slideshow that's a slideshow
preacher not drenched in sweat must not
be very connected to holy spirit there
you go
what's what's the joke now fine you know
whenever i point this out there was one
story that was literally it was
literally not a joke and then i was like
legit what is the joke here and they
were like you're so dumb you don't get
the joke and i'm like i guess so dude i
don't care like you can laugh at me
because i don't get it that's fine it
means i don't read your outlet right you
know it seems that it would have been
like preachers connected to holy spirit
why isn't he sweating they they missed
they missed later i don't think that
one's there it's not funny i'll put it
this way i mean
the onion is not what it used to be they
used to be very political and
this is over the past couple of years
not jokes no yeah but over the past
couple years so probably about two or
three years ago i rediscovered the
videos that they were producing i want
to say between 2008 and 2011. and
they're so
funny their youtube channel was
incredible for just a couple years and
part of it was because they actually had
a tv show and those clips on youtube
were excerpts from them
yeah but they let's be real they used to
be very funny even when they got
political is my point they were still
funny and even when they had a message i
didn't agree with politically i thought
they were hysterical the grabblers video
that was great you know the grabblers no
i don't know that one it's an onion
video it's an onion video we cannot play
it here yeah we definitely can't play it
spicy even though it's on youtube really
funny where basically it's a mockery of
a morning news show and they bring on
this female author to help them
visualize their their stresses and she's
like this little old woman like
everybody has problems with money i want
you to imagine your money problem and
then she basically goes on to describe
jewish people and then makes a bunch of
really offensive jokes but the point was
what was funny about it was that this
little old lady was basically trying to
sneak in like these anti-semitic tropes
and that was the joke that was the onion
that did that they also had that
autistic reporter bit
totally ableist you wouldn't be able to
get away with that these days they had
funny jokes now look i pulled up this
joke and it's okay let me here you go
here's here's their joke
hey current chief of staff mark meadows
it's me jenny thomas wife of clarence
thomas urging you to illegally overturn
the results of the 2020 election as i am
involved with a group of alt-right
radicals who if unhappy with the results
will storm the capitol building in
washington dc on january 6 2021 i agree
with their goals and methodologies
full-heartedly and again i jenny thomas
am unabashedly requesting that this
illegal action should be taken
where's the joke
like this is something ridiculous i
would write if the joke was that like
this is what democrats think a
republican is saying like that would be
the bit i pulled up there 2001. i got
into onion in 2001. boyfriend
ceremoniously dumped i mean these were
the articles and they were and they
would show a picture of a person's face
and they would reuse that same so you
would imagine this is the writer it was
like a fake person or or just some
random stock photo they got so imagining
who was saying it helps
the comedy i thought yeah in the early
days
you know what i think like
it's clapter right you guys know what
claptor is yeah yeah you're just you
just agree there's like a vague you know
set up punchline formula
clapping it's when colbert comes out and
he's like donald trump's dumb and
they'll go
inside clapping is like he didn't say
anything it's not amusement you're going
for it's applause you're going for yeah
so i look at a lot of that and there's a
lot of just avoiding hurting people's
feelings by being offensive now you know
the woke the woke mind virus as elon
musk calls it has infected
all of these comedians on the left you
know and so they're all the jokes that
they would have made years ago that are
funny they're capable of making those
jokes but they're not willing to make
them now because they cross a line an
imaginary line that they made up there
was a really good one they did a couple
of years ago um the onions like 10 years
ago it's patriotic teen fail spanish
and it was just a video where they're
like interviewing this kid as a brave
patriot for failing spanish and
obviously the point of that joke was to
poke fun at the right but i still i
thought it was hilarious when i saw it
and it's a funny video
now it's not it's not just that they
have a left-wing bias it's that today
having a left-wing bias means you have
to explicitly oppose anything that's
even remotely funny
here's one farmer caught googling what
is corn it's like okay what yeah it's
like um
it's a different company with the same
name i don't know no problem man
companies sell and another owner and
then they keep the same name that's
scandalous also i'd be curious to know
because there are clearly some duds here
we're obviously remembering the ones
that were really fun that's why they
stick out to us yeah yeah so i'm
wondering also if there's just a
selection bias here because none of
these are going to stay on the test of
time and maybe probably some boring yeah
but there were a couple funny ones we
saw when we were younger that we really
remember i think that stuff that used to
be funny is no longer funny too because
we get used to it and like you gotta you
gotta one-up it you know you gotta take
it to the next level or or go home there
was one they did too uh it was like uh
new humane um tim what we were just
watching like new humane death penalty
uh contraptions oh the person's head off
it shows they actually did a cgi machine
that clamps the person down and then a
giant robotic claw grabs their head and
spins it and rips it off their body and
then it raises it up and a hammer just
starts bashing it for no reason that was
funny it was funny that was like 10
years ago even stuff like now there's
obviously even with that you could argue
there's vague political undertales you
know they're making a statement about
the death penalty and how about barbaric
they believe it is but it's funny it's
funny you can make a political point
still be funny but they don't it was
funny because after it already killed
the person a hammer starts bashing
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
we'll see you all there
you